I have no interest in becoming a serial
killer so I'm a big believer that your
message should transcend your genre that
as an entrepreneur as a creative what
you stand for as a human being the
positive impact you're trying to make in
the world should transcend the topic and
the industry that you're in so I'm part
of our YouTube mastermind group that was
created by Tim Schmoyer where every week
we get together and it's a bunch of
creators who made you to their full-time
business and we're trying to help each
other out and give each other guidance
on how do you get better and every week
we kind of take turns going around the
table and so yesterday one of the
members that I love dearly Adrian stores
from xoxo cooks was on talking about her
YouTube channel and she has a cooking
channel that shows people how to make
different recipes and what I've been
challenging her on not quite from the
beginning but pretty early on was I want
to see her stand for something I want to
see you have a positive message she's so
creative she's done so many great things
she has a great heart she wants to
contribute back and you see it in bits
and pieces on the channel but
understanding that she's never going to
be the best cook and she's never gonna
have the best you know recipes and
compete with the martha stewart's and
whoever the you know those big people
are but for her it's much more than
message like what is she staying for
bringing that to every video so that
when people watch it they feel inspired
and she's playing with a few different
ideas and try to figure out you know
what that message is and have
incorporated into her cooking videos and
I mentioned to her yesterday on the chat
that i watch the videos because of you
because you're in this group because I
want to support you because I want to
see your videos do well because I want
to you know watch them and and just try
to help out a friend but otherwise you
know I'm not in the cooking I wouldn't
watch your videos if I didn't know you
when was trying to help you out what I
want to like I want you to create
something that I would want to watch
even if I had no interest in the subject
matter because the message is so strong
and so she was thinking about it and
responded well I don't know if I want to
reach non cooks people who don't care
about the food people don't want to know
about the recipe i don't know if that's
my target audience i don't if i should
be trying to address
people and that's when this I have no
interest in being a serial killer came
up because i use Hollywood as an example
where what we are as youtubers and as
entrepreneurs is we should be
storytellers right we are trying to move
people to take action through a story
and there's gonna be movies that you've
walked out of where you felt inspired or
you felt angry or you felt happier you
felt sad and that had a ripple effect
somewhere else in your life and so I use
the example of when I watch a Hollywood
movie I have no interest in becoming a
serial killer but I can watch a movie
and feel inspired or feel angular feel
happy you feel sad and then go out and
make a change in my life where I will
watch movies and have no interest in
becoming a football player or a
basketball player or you know a tech
Titan or any of the different movies
that you watch I will never be that
person I have no interest in becoming
that person I don't want to go out and
race a horse even though I love watching
Seabiscuit but I can learn from the
movie to apply lessons to myself and the
best storytellers do that and as
youtubers that's part of our job we
should be able to reach an audience
wider than what the subject matter is
that we're teaching because the message
that we stand for is so powerful and so
I look at my channel and there's a lot
of non entrepreneurs who watch my
channel at the start of thought why
would an entrepreneur watch my channel
all I talk about is entrepreneurship but
the message of believe has transcended
entrepreneurship where people watch the
videos and they get inspired to go have
an impact on their life and their job
and their family even though they have
zero interest in wanted to become an
entrepreneur and I want this for you and
so when I brought that lineup that I
have no interest in becoming a serial
killer in the call then the other
members of the group started freaking
out in Jason her go from social blade
calm decided he would make this nice
picture that he threw up in the chat
that a voodoo was kind of laughing at
and our facebook fan page I thought it
was funny Jason pops to you for your
on-the-fly photoshop skills but I think
it's also a great lesson that I wanted
to make this video on for you guys
thinking that you only serve a target
audience and yes that is your core base
but hopefully you have a message that
can trance
and that core base to be able to reach
an impact everybody if you can figure
that out then you're on to something
that can really have a big impact in
this point so I'm curious for you guys
what is the message that you have that
transcends your genre your topic what's
the powerful thing that you are all
about leaving in the comments below and
i will join in the discussion i also
want to give a quick shout to send patil
same thank you so much for buying a cup
my book really means a lot to me do you
guys watching if you want to change at a
shadow in your future video make sure to
buy a copy of the book it's really good
at I promise and email in your seats so
we can keep track and send you the
bonuses thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon